will conan be babysitting
i mean
it's soda this is your life
tiger shark bites says how difficult was
it to pick names
funny story about names so you know we
had been throwing around names for a
while
and
we hadn't really like settled on them
and then uh when i walked into the room
at one point i had like gone to the
bathroom i came back and my husband was
filling out the paperwork for the birth
certificate and he just put two of the
names that we had talked about but we
weren't like these are their names he
just
i think he was just like
felt he needed to fill out the paperwork
so that's how we named our voice
[Laughter]
but they were the two
you know names we were thinking of
but i just was like maybe once they're
born we'll talk about it we'll look at
them but once the paperwork was filled
out i was like
all right that sounds good
works for me so i i would say the pa the
hospital paperwork pretty much named our
babies for us and then their middle
names are my grandpa's names
and you know what like
i figured if they're gonna have my
husband's last name then i get to pick
the middle name right
i won that one
so was it difficult yeah it's difficult
you're like picking a name they're going
to use for the rest of their lives so
really difficult
but uh now that we know them we've been
calling them by their names by charlie
and mikey for the last four months we're
like
oh he's a charlie or oh he's a mikey
but like it would have
been that no matter what we named them
so
anyway you're welcome at matt raura says
i have a four month old what's your kids
bedtime routine i have four month old
two two four month i have two four month
old babies too
i can't talk
uh that's cool uh what is our kids
bedtime routine it changes from time to
time i know that doesn't sound like a
routine but like little elements of a
change but they you know it's a bath
then we put them in their sleep thing
then we feed them then we hang out with
them for a little bit until they're
drowsy and then we put them in their
cribs
like i wish i could say we like read
books and then like i you know i sing to
them but they usually fall asleep before
i could do any of that stuff
um
they have very short attention spans
i you know i'm curious to hear what your
bedtime routine is but when we do it
they sleep so it works so we just do
that
you're welcome at
jasondavis929 says will conan be
babysitting
you know it's funny because someone else
asked how i keep conan away from my
children
but will conan be babysitting
i mean
probably not
i babysat conan so it's just weird if
somebody you babysat who's gonna babysit
your kids right
i guess not maybe he's old enough maybe
he can figure it out he has two really
cool kids so he did something right
will conan be babysitting
i mean come on
no
of course not and you knew that you knew
that jason davis
no
first of all he lives too far he always
makes comments about how far away i live
he won't ever drive out here
second
you know i feel like he'll do too many
bits and then the kids will get
irritated and then he'll get irritated
he's not getting the right response
and it just won't work out so no he's
not going to
i want to say you're welcome but i
didn't help raise your kids with this
question
but you're welcome
anyway
[Music]